it's Annie gonna be cooking time it's a
restaurant of the cooking time what am I
supposed to do how am I gonna get this
done just like men how am I gonna pull
this off
what's up everybody I'm chef Marcus and
summer right now you had a Red Rooster
in Harlem today it's all about family
meal which is also the one meal that you
can never ever ever order in any
restaurant family meal is like this
hidden little secret cook server's
partner managers everybody sitting
together everybody eating this an
opportunity for us to see each other as
a family I thought it would be
challenging to have Tiffany take on the
challenge with family show us who you
are get a chance to perform let's go
meet Tiffany in the kitchen hey Tiffany
why are you hey chef how are you so
today you got to make family meal okay
what okay you can't really say no to
Marcus so you're ready I am ready
you better be delicious I will be I
don't want to see any sweet technical
dessert today is nothing to do with
paste right now good luck and I'm gonna
I'm rooting for you
not good I'm gonna let you know I know
you well okay good luck thank you
so when Marcus told me that I was making
family meal today I was just like oh my
goodness so what am I gonna do it's
definitely a lot of pressure because I
have been doing pastries for about 13
years I do not cook I'm pretty much a
home cook one of roosters biggest assets
in any restaurants a sadistic creative
staff everyone that works in the
restaurant is creative in so many ways
do we get a chance to showcase that here
because of family meal so I decided to
use rice and beans because they had
kidney beans already prepares I go
inside the protein walk in to see what
protein is available we have some goat
meat it's like you can't make goat
unless it's Kerrygold
there's no other way to make go so when
went into the produce fridge now to see
what vegetable I can use I saw that
there was some shredded cabbage that's
how I came with the process Carrie go
with steamed cabbage rice and peas and
Festival which is a fry bread so it was
really nervous Epiphany that wasn't a
challenge at all I was done something
more difficult you know but that's the
beautiful thing with cooking
sometimes you need a lot of time and
planning and sometimes just whipping
something up it's the best way I think
people are really rooting for her that
they want her to do really well very
family I've had West Indian Jamaican
food forever I won't make it and Jamie's
also an example of I didn't know she was
cooking so she came in and did family
meal for us and then we actually started
to put on a laughing night we started
with Jamie's dishes on the menu family
meal really shows the best of a
restaurant and why I love to be a
restaurant worker so much we treat the
meal just like we will cook for a guest
and our audience at that moment is our
staff so I'm a little nervous because I
don't know what people are gonna expect
but I hope they enjoy it as much as I'm
enjoying making it for them I learned to
make all these dishes from my
grandmother
her name is hopefully Robeson and she
passed away last week so she's the
reason why I decided to make this meal
and I said one day I'm gonna perfect
these dishes and I'm gonna be famous for
it and look at me now
I mean rooster is really la familia and
the fact that Tiffany is such a love
team member cuz she works hard and she's
on everybody all the time but they also
know because she has the best interest
of the food for the Marigold typically
when I make it I like to marinate my
meat for about two or three days I only
was able to marinate it for literally
like five minutes
and then I had to cook it and then I'm
like man goat takes about three hours so
I had to just turn the oven up all the
way up to 500 degrees boil it for like
30 minutes pop it in the oven just
looking cooked in time the rice and peas
I would normally use a dry coconut and
make my own coconut milk but again
because I didn't have any dry coconut in
the house I just used canned coconut
milk so I can be able to meet the time
frame for family meal so as I'm in the
process of preparing oh I'm almost done
everything is on time behold Marcus
walks in the kitchen see what I've got
here Meyers room what are you gonna do
with that you know we have to add one
more thing for you so you're ready to
serve right yeah you know what we need
because it's pastry we need a good old
Jamaican rum cake for staff as well okay
can you do that we wanted to be savory
and something sweet okay you got it I
need to work on Tiffany goes a little
bit surprised when I handle a bottle of
rum but like any good Jamaican she knew
what to do I'm gonna see what kind of
cake batter that I have already pre-made
all right so I have some vanilla cupcake
mix I'm just going to turn this into a
quick and easy rum cake that's all I can
do right now and I'm just like what am I
supposed to do how am I supposed to get
this done so I literally have to think
off the top of my head how am I gonna
pull this off
[Music]
puts a little room into the cupcake
batter it's not the right way but they
will do at this point it's a team effort
now so right now we have about an hour
and the cupcakes will take about ten
minutes I'll just bake them pop them in
the freezer cool them down ice and
they're real quick the oven at 400
degrees it's making everything cook
really fast so that's what's saving me
right now
so I'm just gonna make some vanilla
whipped cream I'm gonna run and get some
creams in the fridge no make me a fruit
salad it's definitely a lot of pressure
making family meal because to cook for
50 people and you don't know what the
response or the reaction that's going to
be but fortunately a lot of people here
we're very excited for me to make family
meal because they do like my desserts
and then the fact that I have a Jamaican
background and we have a lot of people
from the Caribbean they're just like ooh
trivia food something different than
what they're usually used to having for
family meal making family meal making
sure I'm set up in time I was a little
stressed out a little bit I was just
like man how am I gonna pull this off so
when I was serving family meal I was so
in my head I was like oh my gosh am I
gonna do a good job it's a me gonna be
cooked in time it's a rice gonna be
cooking time I hope everything tastes
good I was really really paranoid she's
taking the number one spot I need
somebody to create another challenge so
far she took my spot we definitely have
to change the menu by the way two or
three of these things that cabbage is
gonna come on the goat is coming up
she's taking over yes you take everyone
I noticed was taking seconds and coming
up to third and the reaction and the
responses is really good really positive
well I think it's amazing about today is
that if you know what's really really
hard for this how did the meal come out
all right good job family meal is also a
moment to come together but we can start
seeing each other whether we work back
of the house in front of the house la
familia you have an opportunity to
really like support one another because
I bet you it's not one of you that is
not going through so I think that's
amazing
when Marcus told me that I did a good
job I was playing it was so amazing I
was like it's like a sigh of relief I'm
like okay he enjoys eating what I make
he likes it I feel like a cloud parent
that was nervous the whole time but he
did such a good job
almost too good I'm like wow she showed
all the cooks a restaurant that has
great family meal will have amazing vibe
and culture and it starts with family
[Music]